you know bill murray is starting some of
the most beloved movies of all time but
bill behind the scenes
could be a very different story
altogether welcome to entertainment
tonight michelle turner is off stories
of bill behaving badly have come up
before in his five decades in hollywood
and now a new accusation has come to
light
inappropriate behavior that's reportedly
the complaint against bill murray which
resulted in the indefinite shutdown of
his latest movie being mortal the studio
is investigating although it's unclear
what murray is accused of doing you're
going to endanger our client the comedy
icon who starred in classics like
ghostbusters and caddyshack was last
seen out at the vanity fair party on
oscar night but the new claim is not the
first time murray's been accused of
misconduct on set alex
all my angels
actress lucy liu alleged that while
filming charlie's angels in 2000 murray
inexplicably started hurling insults at
her
some of the language was inexcusable and
unacceptable i stood up for myself and i
don't regret it there's no need to
condescend or to put other people down
on that same set there's no doubt that's
hot the director accused murray of head
butting him murray has denied this
oscar winner richard dreyfuss also made
claims about murray's behavior he was an
irish drunken bully
is what it was
e.t was on set of what about bob in 1990
it was all smiles while our cameras were
rolling but years later dreyfus claimed
the comedian threw a heavy ashtray at
him during production but luckily missed
he screamed
at the top of his lungs everyone hates
you
you are
you are tolerated
the behind-the-scenes claims may come as
startling news for bill murray fans
nobody knows in america in january the
comedian surprised new yorkers with an
impromptu concert and he stopped by our
office amidst the milestone would have
been 45 years since you joined snl
january 1977 i believe did you know that
well i know i've been paying my phone
bill for a long time now so it's
probably that that's what i was
celebrating
you